It seems today that all you see are D-Class
in jumpsuits and contained SCPs.
But where are those good, old-fashioned explanations
on which we used to rely?
Luckily, there’s SCP Explained.
Lucky there’s a channel who positively can
talk all about those objects that make us
scream and cry...
Anyway, today, we’re going to be looking
at one freakin’ sweet SCP, Lois!
I mean, uh…
Audience.
So put on your best pair of green pants and
a white button-up, and watch out for any roaming
giant chickens, because we’re going to be
taking a look at one of the strangest anomalies
in the Foundation’s history, SCP-5981, otherwise
known as Nuke City.
It’s just another ordinary day in your average,
suburban home, where you live with a bumbling
idiot of a father, a caring, though slightly
aloof mother, a sister who seems to be blamed
for everything that goes wrong around here,
a baby brother who you suspect is secretly
a highly intelligent evil genius bent on world
domination, and your talking dog, whose sentience
you have never once questioned.
Okay, this might not resemble your life exactly,
but it is definitely just another average
day in your life.
You hear the front door ring, and you rush
to answer it.
Opening the door, you see that it’s none
other than Matt, your friend who is absolutely
obsessed with Family Guy.
The animated adult sitcom about the Griffin
family, whose combination of wacky antics,
pop culture references, and irreverent comedic
stylings is just about the funniest thing
in the world to Matt, who’s standing right
there in a Stewie Griffin t-shirt.
You’re pretty sure Matt’s the biggest
Family Guy-guy in the world, and while you
just think the show is slightly amusing, you
kind of admire his unhinged fanaticism over
it.
He’s seen every episode multiple times,
owns all of the home media releases, and even
has a multitude of Family Guy collector's
pieces and memorabilia, including a mint in
the box action figure of Peter Griffin signed
by the show’s creator, Seth McFarlane!
If anyone’s been keeping Family Guy on-air
for the past 15 years, it’s definitely Matt.
And because he’s at your house right now,
that could only mean one thing — a new Family
Guy premiere!
That’s right.
Ever since Matt decided he loved Family Guy
above all else, it would also mean he felt
it was necessary to make every single episode
airing as they first aired.
If Matt was standing outside your door, it
meant that he wanted to watch a new episode
of Family Guy with you, like you two usually
did together every week.
While a part of you didn’t understand Matt’s
obsession, you still enjoyed the show and
more importantly, spending quality time together
with your friend.
“Hey Peter.”
He says, in his best Joe Swanson imitation.
You roll your eyes as he waltzes into your
house without any further explanation.
Matt, excited as ever, walks into your living
room and plops himself down onto the couch.
As usual, he explains that a brand new episode
of Family Guy is about to air in an hour,
and he was wondering if you wanted to watch
it with him.
Well, it’s not like he’s ever given you
a choice, you think.
You say the same thing you always do.
“Sure, Matt!
You always know what my answer to that question
is!”
As if Matt expected any other response from
you, he becomes all giddy and excited.
Oh Matt, you strange, strange human being.
An hour later, the episode begins.
That broadway style intro kicks in and you
find yourself wanting more and more to kick
back and relax with Peter and the gang.
But something is off.
It’s not uncomfortable to watch or anything,
but all the while, you get the feeling that
this episode of Family Guy is somehow different
than all the others you’ve seen.
The plot sounds like something out of a dream,
even for a show as strange as Family Guy.
In the episode, Brian Griffin, the family’s
talking dog, begins dating a woman who he
discovers has fish-like gills on her body.
She claims that she’s a mutant, and her
body has been altered as a result of exposure
to nuclear energy in her hometown, a place
she calls “Nuke City”.
In spite of the woman’s appearance, Brian
continues to see her over a series of dates.
Peter Griffin, however, becomes obsessed with
the idea of Nuke City, having never heard
of it before and finding the concept of a
town in constant nuclear fallout, populated
by mutated civilians to be exceptionally exciting,
and he pushes Brian to stay with the girl.
Over time, Brian and the rest of the cast
go to visit his girlfriend and her family
in Nuke City itself, which is depicted as
a half-destroyed town full of strange, wacky
mutants.
Peter loves it so much that, in true Family
Guy fashion, he decides to break out in song,
singing a musical number about how much he
loves Nuke City, and how everyone should visit
the place, and even offers detailed directions
on how to go there.
As the plot progresses, the Griffins, who
are eating dinner at the mutant woman’s
house, discover that their youngest son, the
evil, talking baby known as Stewie, has disappeared!
Unable to find him, Brian begins to look a
bit deeper into the issue, and discovers that
his girlfriend’s father, for unknown reasons,
has kidnapped Stewie, and is currently located
at the town’s nuclear power plant.
Brian’s mind immediately jumps to the worst
case scenario, which is that Stewie Griffin
was kidnapped in order to be exploited for
his high intelligence and world-ending inventions.
Brian rushes over to the power plant, with
the rest of the family in tow, wondering how
and why he would abandon his date in the middle
of their meal.
At the power plant, Brian faces off against
the kidnapper, his date’s father.
After a lengthy explanation of needing Stewie
to manufacture a giant nuclear explosion that
would turn the entire world into mutants,
a fight between Brian and the mutant breaks
out.
Thankfully, the dog wins, and pushes his date’s
father to his death as he falls into the nuclear
reactor.
This triggers a meltdown and a consequential
explosion, which the Griffins narrowly manage
to escape in the episode’s final scene.
Brian is thankful Stewie is safe, but laments
the loss of his girlfriend.
The ending joke, however, is that the explosion
caused the residents of Nuke city to mutate
even further, with Brian’s girlfriend stepping
in front of the camera, slightly out of view
as a gigantic sludge monster, who asks the
dog for a goodbye kiss.
When the episode finishes, you’re generally
surprised.
What a strange, great piece of entertainment.
Matt absolutely loved it, and leaps from the
couch over to your desktop computer and immediately
starts searching for guided tours of Nuke
City.
But for some reason, this doesn’t strike
you as odd.
Of course Matt wants to visit Nuke City.
You do too!
The episode was practically a glorified advertisement
for how cool the place is, with all of those
mutants walking around and the sweet feeling
of nuclear radiation permeating the air and
getting into your pores.
You wouldn’t want to visit anywhere else
over the summer, so you sit down to start
looking as well.
There’s not much you can find on the internet
about the place, but there is a link that
seems to be the hub for all things Nuke City.
A website titled, well, “visitnukecity.com”.
The page looks incredibly high effort, with
all sorts of quality photos of Nuke City and
its freakish residents.
It even offered guided tours, and a shop with
tons of Nuke City merch for you to purchase!
But most importantly, it had directions on
how to reach Nuke City, and they just happened
to line-up with the directions that Peter
Griffin himself had given in the show.
As it turned out, Nuke City was strangely
close to where you and Matt lived.
In fact, it was located just off of the interstate.
You could go visit any time you wanted, and
that’s exactly what you were going to do!
A few days later, you packed your bags for
an extended stay and hit the road, following
the directions to a tee.
Though unsure why, a part of you felt like
this was all a dream, and that you weren’t
actually going to find Nuke City.
But that couldn’t be, it had to be real!
There was a Family Guy episode about it, and
that website, and more importantly, you and
Matt both knew that it was real.
Fortunately, those fears were quelled as soon
as you entered the city limits and gazed upon
the town’s greatness for yourself.
There it was, Nuke City.
Looking just as dilapidated and grimey as
it did in the episode, with its red, smog-filled
sky and its broken down buildings that were
all modified into tacky tourist shops and
attractions.
It was perfect, and you couldn’t be happier.
All over the town were the mutated civilians,
with their discolored skin and cartoon-like
features that made radiation poisoning look
like a fun condition to have.
They seemed to be enjoying themselves, even.
Guiding tours, operating shops, generally
having a great time living in their slightly
post-apocalyptic society.
Over the next few days, you and Matt lived
it up in Nuke City, enjoying the strange food
and sightseeing the freaky landmarks, such
as the giant tower of human skeletal remains,
or the mutated consciousness blob that lived
in what used to be a public pool.
You were even encouraged to feed the thing,
and toss him graham crackers from over the
balcony!
Overall, you felt like you had a great time
in Nuke City, and the episode itself couldn’t
compare to how fun the actual place was.
You experienced things in those few days you’d
never experience elsewhere, such as the Nuke
Slides water park, or winning it big in Nuke
City’s many themed casinos.
You even brought a few pieces of irradiated
rubble for your family to enjoy as souvenirs.
It was an unforgettable experience, and you
planned to go back someday.
At least, if you got out of the situation
you currently found yourself in, with your
entire home being ransacked by black-suited
agents and armed guards.
That’s right.
Only a few days after you had returned from
Nuke City, you woke up to the sound of banging
on your front door, and before you knew it,
your house was being raided by what you assumed
was the U.S government, though you weren’t
exactly sure why.
After being transported to an unknown location
and sitting you down in a strange-looking
room, the suited men started asking you questions.
All of which pertained to Nuke City.
You explained the entire story, how you and
Matt went after seeing the Family Guy episode,
and how you didn’t see why there was anything
strange about going to an ordinary tourist
destination like Nuke City.
The suited man slides you a digital tablet,
showing you overhead security footage of what
appeared to be your car, exiting the interstate
on the day you traveled to Nuke City.
Instead of traveling down the extensive exit,
your car trails off into the woods, disappearing.
Four days later, it reappears in the same
spot, driving back home as if nothing happened.
You’re shocked.
Where was the road to Nuke City?
You knew you had gone there!
Heck, you even had the merchandise to prove
it.
You glanced down at your Nuke Slides water
park shirt, pointing it out to the agent.
The man got up and left the room, and you
could see him discussing something with a
lab-coat-wearing woman outside of the room.
When they come back in, it’s with a syringe
filled with a strange-looking orange liquid.
The man tells you that there is no such place
as Nuke City, and you have no recollection
of going there.
For whatever reason, his suggestion seems
strangely appealing, and the way he keeps
repeating those words keeps you entranced.
When you least expect it, the woman inserts
the syringe into your back.
You fall over, slamming your head into the
table.
When you wake up, you have no memory of anything
that happened over the past week.
You remember watching Family Guy with Matt,
though you can’t remember what the episode
was about for the life of you, and you remember
having a completely ordinary, almost boring
week after that.
You never think of Nuke City, or that episode
of Family Guy, ever again.
So, what happened here?
Well, you, and just about every other person
in the country who watched Family Guy that
week were subject to an anomaly the SCP Foundation
has designated as SCP-5981.
SCP-5981 is a curious case indeed, as the
anomaly itself isn’t the episode that aired,
but the concept of Nuke City, a fictional
U.S city located at the intersection of Route
93 and 93 Alternate.
The city’s fictionalized history claims
that it was founded in the early 1940s, but
was subject to a nuclear strike in 1966.
The attacking party varies between accounts,
with some saying it was Cuba, or the Soviet
Union, or even an accidental nuclear detonation
by U.S military personnel.
A very small percentage of accounts of SCP-5981
claimed that it was the Daevite Empire, the
ancient, anomalous society that had disappeared
centuries ago, who had launched the strike.
Whatever the case, the story goes that after
the fallout, most of the city’s inhabitants
not only survived the attack, but became mutated
in ways inconsistent with the reality of radiation
poisoning.
Sprouting extra limbs, organs, gills, in a
beneficial way instead of a lethal one.
Now, you might be thinking that SCP-5981 is
a memetic agent, and anyone exposed to Nuke
City will believe that it’s a real place,
but that just isn’t the case.
Most subjects exposed to SCP-5981 do not believe
that Nuke City exists, and no future consequences
will occur.
It just so happens that you and your friend
Matt were particularly unlucky, and fell consequence
to SCP-5981’s poorly understood side-effect,
which causes those exposed to Nuke City to
not question it, and fully believe that the
city exists.
Those who do so, and attempt to visit the
city, will disappear from reality shortly
after entering SCP-5981’s “city limits”.
Once they leave, they’ll reappear in reality,
with fully formed memories of visiting Nuke
City and possibly even some paraphernalia
related to the city, such as T-Shirts with
the slogan “I survived Nuke City”, vials
of nuclear byproducts, photos and postcards,
negotiable U.S currency won in Nuke City’s
casinos, or personalized rubble intended to
function as a souvenir.
Of course, those who return from Nuke City
are entirely safe, despite supposedly having
visited a place with as high a nuclear radiation
count as SCP-5981.
Those who visit the area the town is supposedly
located in who are unaware of Nuke City will
instead find nothing but an abandoned Department
of Transportation building, leaving the city’s
existence accessible only to those who know
of it and fully believe in it.
The Foundation first became aware of SCP-5981,
Nuke City, after the aforementioned episode
of Family Guy aired on television, labeled
Season 13, Episode 7.
Within a day, the website “visitnukecity.com”
appeared, and according to Foundation estimates,
over 200,000 civilians visited SCP-5981 before
the Foundation caught on that this phenomenon
was anomalous.
After this, containment procedures were established,
with the road leading to the city being closed
off, and a webcrawler being programmed to
remove any mention of Nuke City from the internet.
Anyone the Foundation could track down as
having visited Nuke City, like you and Matt,
were paid a visit by Foundation agents, interrogated,
and amnesticized.
But most importantly, the Foundation made
sure to see what was happening behind the
scenes at Fox Studios, who produced Family
Guy at the time.
Seth Macfarlane, the executive producer and
creator of Family Guy, was given a stern talking
to by Foundation agents, but even then, his
interview offered very little understanding
of how SCP-5981 originated or why the episode
was even produced.
The Foundation forced him to produce a statement
that said that SCP-5981 was not real, and
was simply an element of fiction that the
writers had made up for the show.
After this, the Foundation removed the episode
from public distribution, and after three
months, way after the hype surrounding Nuke
City had passed, a complete and total information
blackout on the episode was put into place,
essentially wiping this episode of Family
Guy from the minds of the general public through
the use of mass amnesticization tactics.
Unlike those with Macfarlane, interviews with
the cast and crew of Family Guy revealed that
they believed that SCP-5981 was entirely real,
and the episode would shine light on a lesser-known
tourist destination.
While Macfarlane claimed that he had just
came up with the concept for the show, while
under hypnosis, the man revealed that he had
been approached by an individual wearing all-black
robes and a cone-shaped hood prior to the
episode’s conception.
This entity instructed Macfarlane to produce
an episode revolving around a nuclear town,
where in its climax, a resident would be murdered
by being pushed into a nuclear reactor.
MacFarlane could not recall anything else
about this memory when brought back from hypnosis.
Still, the Foundation continued to monitor
for incidents revolving SCP-5981.
While some still tried to visit the city,
these events were far and few between.
A few notable events include a civilian who
did not return from SCP-5981, but whose family
was sent a letter from “Nuke City Hospital”
explaining that they had been killed in a
motorcycle accident while touring the city.
Another involved a heavily injured civilian
returning from SCP-5981 after an altercation
with a street gang.
Their blood revealed traces of irradiated,
nuclear radiation, yet no ill effects aside
from those received in the street gang beatdown
were noted.
Another incident involved the television channel
Cartoon Network receiving a tape containing
an entire season of a cartoon revolving around
three mutated dogs and their lives, which
was being pitched by Radioactive Studios,
a company supposedly located in SCP-5981.
The final incident involved several U.S politicians
visiting SCP-5981 and accidentally being caught
in an explosion that occurred as a result
of a janitor pushing a plant worker inside
a nuclear reactor in the city’s main power
plant.
Much like what occurred in the episode, this
resulted in an explosion that destroyed a
massive portion of SCP-5981.
The Foundation could do nothing but cover
up the politician’s deaths and increase
security outside of SCP-5981’s entrance.
The case of SCP-5981 is certainly mysterious
and gives very little answers, but it’s
definitely one of the most unique anomalies
that the Foundation has had to deal with.
Keeping true to the spirit of Family Guy,
let’s end with a cutaway gag.
Holy crap, viewer!
This is just like the time Dr. Bright visited
Nuke City!
Now go check out “SCP-2316 - The Bodies
in the Water” and “SCP-1472 - Multiverse
Strip Club” for more anomalous locations
that are brain-breakingly strange!